il fait encore nuit sur le quartier de
malaz quand nous pénétrons dans le
centre d'accueil de l'association aïna
une grande maison à une dizaine de km du
centre d'antananarivo oui
landry est assistante sociale au centre
d'accueil pointé au classement bien
réveillé pourquoi il faut se lever
aussitôt
prenez un lectra qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire
le matin faire le lit et puis après la
gauche et en hiver les enfants ont droit
à une douche à l'eau chaude mais il faut
aller la chercher avec un saut dans la
cuisine 50 enfants vivent au centre
certains sont orphelins d'autres ont été
placés par le juge parce que leurs
parents étaient dans l'incapacité de
s'occuper d'eux ils sont ici entourée
d'attentions d'affection mais la
discipline stricte à 5h30 le matin pour
hasnia et tous les enfants du centre
c'est opération coup de balai et dans la
salle à manger à l'heure du petit
déjeuner personne ne commence à manger
avant le top départ donné par
l'éducatrice
[Musique]
pendant que les enfants prennent leur
petit déjeuner nous prenons la direction
de la pouponnière sept petits de moins
de 6 ans vivent dans cette annexe du
centre c'est les enfants de la
pouponnière lcf motion elle s'appelle
entre chacun d'eux à un nom qui a fait
qu pioli lèvent le doigt
les droits
[Musique]
fidel lui à 9 ans malnutries maltraités
ils ne savaient pas marcher quand il est
arrivé au centre il ya un an et demi
victime d'un grave accident de moto il
en a gardé de lourdes séquelles et doit
suivre tous les jours de longues séances
de rééducation
mais il a retrouvé le sourire et de
bonnes rondeurs pourquoi les enfants ils
sont ici cheetahs et ati j'avais
évidemment de nous doit hasnia pourquoi
tu es ici c'est malhonnête des assignats
avait deux ans quand elle est arrivée au
centre
sa mère venait de mourir après avoir mis
au monde son septième enfant son père
handicapé ne pouvait pas nourrir une
telle famille les sept enfants ont été
placés
à madagascar 80% des enfants arrêtent
l'école avant l'âge de 11 ans pour
travailler et le niveau de l'école
publique est tellement bas que
l'association aïna a décidé de
scolariser les enfants du centre dans
cette école privée
il est 7 heures les cours commencent
seulement dans une heure assia répète
ses leçons cherchait tesla est le
pluriel tremplin sont assez difficiles
le français c'est très difficile est-ce
que tu connais une chanson en français
oui j'en vois je suis à toi
au sort de la mémoire dans
102 taqwa jeu
loi pour moi 8 heures les cours
commencent
[Musique]
les gens de la mouvance madagascar
madagascar se trouve dans l'hémisphère
sud
d'un côté de la afe dans l'océan indien
pour chaque enfant
l'association aïna paye 20 euros par
mois pour les coller de transport
auxquels s'ajoutent 100 euros pour la
prise en charge au centre d'accueil 120
euros au total financé par des dons
d'entreprises et par un peu plus de 300
parent de l'hexagone et de la réunion
en rentrant de l'école hasnia va rendre
visite à son père pal prison d'insein
avant la mort de son épouse
le père de la snia était cultivateur à
l'époque il ne gagnait même pas 1 euro
par jour pour nourrir six enfants a
tenté il y à peu le père de hasna
vivaient encore dans une misérable
cabane en bois aujourd'hui dans cette
maison il est gardien il fait le ménage
il s'occupe des animaux pour 20 euros
par mois
est-ce que tu comprends que c'est
difficile de vivre avec lui pour le
moment non est ce que tu espères vivre
avec ton père bientôt et vous monsieur
vous pensez que ce sera possible pour
que la snia retourne vivre chez son père
il faudrait une décision du juge un jour
peut-être
l'association aïna elle est prête à
l'accompagner jusqu'à l'âge adulte
l'aider à faire des études à trouver un
travail
devenir autonome quand tu seras
tranquille ou de vie vive
outre m
rêvant elsa caire
rêve ou de vie rêvant elle vivote rêve
montez à cannes
[Musique]